[Musique]
vincent vinel bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau tv 78 on est ravi
de vous avoir
on a la chance de pouvoir parce que vous
êtes ivry noir donc vous êtes venu
presque en voisin oui les noirs
représentent aulas 18 et on a plein de
choses à se raconter donc les gens les
gens qui prennent le train vous
connaissent les gens qui regardent de
voice vous connaissent les gens qui
lisent des livres aussi peu vous
connaître ça fait quand même pas mal de
choses
on va commencer par le début vous êtes
jeune vous avez quel âge j'ai 21 ans 21
ans
alors on vous connaît pas ce que vous
allez participer à célèbres comme on
peut qualifier ça au dessus du crochet
télé crochet the voice et l année
dernière oui comment vous avez été
repérés ou est ce que c'était si vous
êtes inscrit un nom comme ça c'est bien
en fait j'ai joué à un jeu au piano à
saint-lazare mais comme souvent
d'ailleurs ainsi est un jour comme tous
les autres en tenait il ya une testeuse
qui est passé par hasard je travaille
pour the voice vous n'avez pas la voix
de maïté un temps combiné en gros voilà
elle est venue elle a dit bonjour je
travaille pour de vrai sur un mois la
première réaction que première réaction
que j'ai c'est bien sûr la blague a
laissé sa sur lequel marc contacté en
fait elle va s'accrocher
oui elle m'a proposé de venir au casting
et voilà d'accord donc en fait on va
retracer un peu votre votre jeune et
courtenay en 100 m ça va être long mais
très riche et bien remplie mais bon
comme moi j'ai eu la chance de lire
votre livre qu on part un peu plus tout
à l'heure moi je connais le début donc
en fait il se trouve que vous avez été
adoptée à 18 mois
en bulgarie oui voilà par des parents
français donc des yvelines et que
ils se sont très vite aperçu que vous
aviez l'oreille absolue
oui c'était il ya une histoire qui est
quand même incroyable c'est que votre
maman en bulgarie pour vous rassurer
vous chante une petite comptine maman
les p'tits bateaux un ami avait oublié
oui
non mais ça remonte parti début d'accord
et du cou qu'est ce que tu faisais le
deuxième jour de ta naissance
bon on va pas aller si loin mais presque
donc dans petite comptine vous l'avez
imprimés si on peut lire les petits
bateaux voilà et ce qui s'est passé ce
qu'à votre retour en france je les
ressentais voilà le lien
oui comme de rien n'était mais parce que
on a tous une mémoire une mémoire à long
terme et on met tous dans notre tête des
petites bribes qu'on ressort quand on
est un enfant et moi naturellement comme
je vois pas grand chose c'est l'oreille
c'est la musique est privilégiée c'est
votre sens premier
oui c'est ça d'accord j'ai parlé j'ai
chanté avant de parler voilà terre que
mes parents parce qu'à l'époque c'était
du coup à l'orphelinat il n'arrivait pas
les toits de faire parler ouais on est
parti boire un café ils sont partis avec
moi que moi j'avais peur du retour
chantant et là on est en fait j'ai
chanté voilà parce que vu une musique
dans le dans le café j'ai championnat
les clochers le champ exact d'accord
après bon bah vous avez suivi des études
comme tous les jeunes français et vous
avez développé un amour de la musique
très tôt
oui comment ça s'est passé vous avez dit
je veux c'est quoi l'histoire et gérer
ces pavés jamais non mais j'en rêvais de
jeu richard tu prends le bus est prévu
aujourd'hui je rêvais d'être chanteur
voilà voilà
mais depuis le début parce que
j'écoutais de la musique et je me
rappelle parce qu'à l'époque je le
saoulais mes parents parce que quand on
était en voiture j'avais mon petit alors
mon walkman à cassette 9 heures
et je chantais dans la voiture sauf que
je chantais une deuxième voie qui
n'existait pas dans qui n'existaient pas
forcément un peu comme une polyphonie
oui oui c'est ça faisait une polyphonie
c'est ce que mes parents qui avaient pas
le bon mais vous avez quand même
continuer sur cette voie vous souhaitez
votre vocation vous ai dit je veux être
musicien chanteur
ça fait très miss france mais faut
croire en ses rêves
mais oui la preuve voilà j'ai fait une
école de radio en attendant oui
l'accordeur de piano step avec cliff
non j'ai pas mais c'est pas que j'ai pas
aimé en fait c'est que c'était trop
solitaire comme métier comme métier
j'aime bien parler aux gens j'aime bien
ouais je suis très sociable d'accord et
du coup vous êtes dit je me tourne à la
radio oui donc après ça vous donner quoi
comme diplôme c'est des conneries aussi
une école d'animation à l'échelle +3 à
l'échelle 3 / nationale donc en fait
j'ai un bac + 3 sans avoir le bac
très bien vous avez donc pour vous faire
plaisir vous alliez dans les gares à
chanter et jouer du piano
oui alors au début je suis tombé dessus
par hasard parce que je rentrais du
travail
en fait et je suis tombé dessus j'ai
joué et des gens qui sont venus qui ont
applaudi
j'ai fait d'accord ouais si je suis
revenu un président pour le plaisir et
et alors qu'est ce que vous chantiez
qu'est-ce que vous jouiez 1 je faisais
des mashup savez quoi je mettais plein
de musique ensemble et je les mélange
est en fait je faisais en une seule
chanson oui en fait je
j'ai parmelin vente et agen 21 born to
games and style qui est un condensé de
born to be alive again même style
d'accord et evan harris est ce que je
faisais partie de morceaux connus qui me
plaisait oui et vous où vous les
arranger à votre sauce cola puis après
je trie mes sketches à côté justement
dans le livre vous dites je suis dans
les gares tgv de alors la page 402 oui
je le dis troisième chapitre la 12e
ligne et tout ça voilà l'idée à 3 vous
avez dit mes chansons et mes sketches
alors ça m'a interpellé meskhètes ça
veut dire quoi et parce que je me suis
toujours gagner un cadeau on est
d'accord
derrière le piano y est je suis toujours
parti du principe
que l'on peut allier musique et humour
ah bon parce que je suis un mec très
féminine et crédits d'impôt du mois
exactement wifi
vous pourriez le premier jour a appris
m'ont viré non mais t'as qu'a pensé tout
réside alors oui et alors voilà j'ai
fait des sketches et je suis parti dans
un idée de faire un one man show en
alliant beaucoup de musique et de
l'humour est hors jeu testé mes sketches
à saint lazare en fait en même temps que
vos chambres en kraft est oui parce que
la gare s'est très c'est très c'est très
particulier comme ambiance parce que si
vous jouez bien et si vous êtes
intéressant les gens s'arrêtent et vous
écoute si nouristan bon oui donc faut
tenir les gars à une zone de passage est
bien celui-là on transforme la gare ont
un lieu de rendez vous ouais on va
coûter c'est génial on va avoir un petit
reportage sur vous en trop bien trop
bien rien on se retrouve d'accord a tout
de suite
m
pour les fans de l'émission difficile
aujourd'hui de dissocier vincent vinel
de lose yourself le 18 février il tente
l'aventuré voice et cartonne avec le
titre des mines m
l'aventuré ça se passe plutôt bien
jusque là j'ai l'impression
plein de bonnes rencontres des moments
musicaux c'est top
ça fait super plaisir d'avoir un coup de
projecteur sur soi et en même temps
voilà ça nous permet de nous exprimer de
pouvoir transmettre la passion de la
musique qui est je pense que c'est
important de pouvoir le transmettre avec
un maximum de personnes parce que la
musique c'est fait pour partager
mal voyant de naissance vincent vinel à
seulement la vingtaine et l'oreille
absolue
celui qu'on surnomme le héros de la gare
saint lazare est originaire des
clayes-sous-bois il était de retour dans
sa commune pour un showcase
il chante bien il est super gentil
vincent a une voix extraordinaire il
fait passer des évolutions
intense aussi bien
non mais c'est pas que pour
j'ai moi même et à ma femme sa
simplicité son talon et puis de
l'énergie et il a un talent fou c'est un
chanteur et musicien
depuis toujours il dit que pour ça qu'il
est tout petit il vit que pour la
musique mais je m'attendais pas à ce que
les gens ressentent sa musique de cette
manière et soit aussi enthousiaste
du côté du télé crochet vincent continue
l'aventuré dans l'équipe du chanteur
mika
samedi dernier s'est qualifiée pour les
tirer
[Musique]
voilà donc là c'était les débuts de the
voice en fait vous étiez candidat vous
êtes allé loin dans l'aventuré
maintenant on est en juillet dernier
vous avez sorti ce livre vincent vinel
sortir de l'ombre
oui d'écouter mon livre voilà c'est
votre livre grande votre vie du début a
maintenant on apprend plein de choses
comment se passe le télé crochet comment
se passe la vie d'un jeune adolescent
jeunes adultes avec ses forces et ses
faiblesses
le temps des forces vous en avez pas mal
on avec cette oreille absolue je soulève
de la fonte tous les jours c'est ça
voilà je me tue les types
il permet c'est hyper musique voilà
voyez pas là aussi ça oui bon c'est à
dire que vous avez la capacité de vous
souvenir de de plein de choses
oui j'ai j'ai aucun numéro de téléphone
enfin j'ai pas née dans la tête vous
voyez d'ailleurs des autres celle aux
[Rires]
caisses qui a d'autres aussi bons qu'ils
vous êtes quelqu'un d'extrêmement vif et
et qui comprend vite donc
l'inconvénient c'est que vous vous
ennuyez aussi assez vite je crois oui un
satan voilà tout le temps bamanans
ladite moineau l'on devient la vraie
n'est pas bon mais c'est cool à la plus
que deux minutes alors de peu de toi
exact donc ce livre moi je conseille à
tout le monde de le dire parce que c'est
une belle histoire qui donne pleins
d'espoir pour tout le monde 00h03 prends
tes rêves
c'était le but en fait c'est un peu le
but d'un d'un malvoyant ou d'un d'une
personne à mobilité réduite de dire aux
gens allez on se réveille et je veux
dire qu'est-ce qu'on a un petit handicap
ou qu'on voit pas grand chose que l'on
peut pas faire plein de choses de ouf
voilà donc la preuve elle est là sur ce
plateau aujourd'hui vous allez vous
participer à l'émission touche pas à mon
poste
oui deux fois par semaine en ce moment
oui vous jouez du piano
oui et vous allez surtout c'est ça qui
m'intéresse le plus bientôt sortir un
album alors racontez moi ce que vous
pouvez dire ça va hein
l'album est prévu pour candice est
prévue pour début 2010 8 d'accord voilà
j'y vois là on en est en plein dessus en
emploi et on est en plein dedans
vous avez sorti un single j'imagine le
signaler en mastering bilatérales avant
single sais c'est qu'il a écrit qu'il a
composées alors c'est moi qui l'ait
composer avec un collègue à moi qui
travaille avec moi je roule sur écoute
bizou les textes et les textes c'est un
peu tout le monde
c'est en fait adaptable à tout le monde
en a dit à toi qui fais le café bien
faire 20 minutes c'est bon c'est vrai
oui oui parce que j'aime en dessous va
être aidé à bonn mélanger les choses et
oui mais je fais de la pop ouverte c'est
à dire vrai c'est de la pop où on met
plein de choses dedans et je vais me
défoncer le micro et
et du français ou chantôme oui oui oui
bon et mikhail les écouter votre ancien
coach ils n'ont pas encore encore
j'aimerais bien penser que ça va lui
plaire
je sais pas timos il m'envoie ses
chaussures dans la tronche ne sais que
c'est pas bien
ouais bon donc on va avoir un single qui
sort bientôt
oui suivi d'un album oui donc vous avez
signé dans une maison de disque on dit
comme ça encore oui oui je suis
encouragé ses formules à hérisser chez
universal ok donc là vous consacrez je
ne sais votre vie à la musique c'est le
rêve qui se réalise
ça y est c'est juger n'est fini baba on
attend la sortie
ben je reviendrai bon viendra nous voir
avec le disque avec plusieurs et en
attendant on lit le livre
ouais c'est celui-là folie mais les
réseaux sociaux bat vincent vinel
partout il n'y a pas je suis pareil je
sais pas tout je suis une pieuvre je
suis pas sûr que tentaculaire cette
tentaculaire et ben bravo et merci a
bientot a très vite à on n'est pas loin
et ben oui c'est vrai par est finalement
c'est vrai evidian salut
[Musique]